New York's major utility company is
investigating an explosion at a power
substation that lit up both the night
sky and Twitter the eerie blue light
could be seen for miles and led to
confusion and even some panic last night
it was caused by a transformer explosion
in Queens Michelle Miller shows us how
the light mystery fueled wild
speculation on light online Michelle
good morning good morning there were no
injuries reported in the explosion and
power is restored to the area and while
there wasn't an alien invasion in New
York City we can report that the
mysterious blue illumination scared many
people while lighting up social media
it's not supposed to look like that in
the night sky the New York City skyline
was mysteriously illuminated last night
it's flashing it's the sky looks like
the end of the world or something with a
glowing shade of blue what is that holy
the sky make such an eerie blue and
everything was crazy sending many people
into a confused panic way of being
attacking this is our terrorist attacks
heard like boom boom boom boom boom like
that so as I heard that I got scared
turning others to social media for
answers like aliens hacker looked like a
UFO coming from the sky but the
explanation for this blue light mystery
was a transformer energy company con
Edison's Astoria power facility it
caught fire causing power outages and
transportation delays across the area
flights at LaGuardia Airport were
grounded for at least 45 minutes
and many terminals wit dark passengers
aboard planes could see the glowing blue
lights from the sky and on the ground as
planes waited to take off insane in its
pulsating
flights are back in the air power has
been restored and the mystery has been
solved honey check the news still many
were left in awe what is that blue light
in the sky look it's off power was also
cut to Rikers Island one of the nation's
largest prisons but no incidents were
reported con Edison told us the reason
the entire sky lit up was an electrical
fault on the one hundred and thirty
eight thousand volt equipment that
caused an electrical arc flash which
made light visible across the entire
night sky no it wasn't men in black
Michelle I don't know I want to
protectively pledged my allegiance to
our alien overlords I'll just put that
out there